Sam Smith Tweets this out okay this is
going to be special Grammys okay and he
posts the picture and by the way if you
saw his performance it was just like a
little now's X and it's it's something
that it's very provocative you get a lot
of eyeballs and all this other stuff
CBS responds and says you can say that
again we are ready to worship
CBS Sports no this is not CBS underscore
Larry Jackson's account no okay that's
got a CBS and it's a bot this is this
CBS account with a yellow badge next to
it not even blue because when you're
media they give you that little yeah
check mark right there how do you how do
you look at this Kai when you see
something like this you're so the reason
why I'm asking you is the following how
old are you Kai I'm 24. okay 24 years
old the person that probably tweeted
this it's probably my it's probably your
age right which is insane sure yeah now
it's wild now to have something like
that going out how number one how bad of
a look is that on CBS horrible okay so
so horrible in what way like is this
thing gonna be like it's going to go
away you know sweep under the rug I
think just like Roger said earlier in
terms of the new Cycles are so quick
here that yes this is one of those
things it's going to be it's going to be
really bad for another 24 hours and then
the World's Gonna Move On nobody's gonna
care that's really where things are at
this point and that's that's how so the
people that do mess up that make these
big mistakes and you know from getting
arrested to doing things like this
there's so much information and their
attention span is so short that like
mind you the guy did a satanic music
video live on this thing worshiping that
he was the devil and then CBS is saying
yeah we're here to worship they're
obviously not talking about Christianity
which whatever your religious beliefs is
but there's a they don't care they're
out in the open but like you said this
story after today nobody's gonna talk
about it no until you have some other
Hollywood spectacle in which they uh
essentially raise Satanism which which
will happen of course um it's the most
important thing to come out of the
Grammys I was completely and totally
justified in including Harry Styles in
my 14th annual International worst
dressed list did you see with
discoveries
you don't like how he dresses well
here's the thing four or five years ago
he was on the best dress I mean he
dressed like a pruner he's wearing you
know cool button
it would be very weird if I wore
something like that you know Roger
here's my here's my question to all of
you you guys like is this just like that
just like that performance type
situation the same thing with CBS are
they doing it for the eyeballs Pat and
just because think about it not only
we're talking about it I was at the
supermarket somebody else was like did
you see his uh people were talking about
it and now you're looking at him there's
eyeballs more followers more people or
is it just oh sure because you know like
you're you're watching a satanic
performance and then like people like
wearing outfits like that it's like what
is it just for the attention by the way
can you please go back 30 seconds and uh
uh Eric if you're in the back actually
play this put the screenplay just let it
play and just the performance he's got
you know they're doing what they're
doing
okay
and then watch at the end
okay and they're gonna go to commercial
they're gonna cut the commercial ready
CBS
[Applause]
watch watch
[Laughter]
I didn't even notice that timing by the
way we can't make this stuff
and then yesterday he did talk about we
can't let big Pharma pay the amount of
money okay for diabetes many of you in
here are taking the medication they can
increase in more than 35 dollars I'm
like listen you're calling that big
Pharma but you know I don't know what
percentage of CNN's money comes from Big
Pharma I don't know what percentage of
these big media companies money comes
from Big Pharma what do you mean you're
calling those guys out so bash them
while you're giving a speech but behind
closers take their money of course and
that and how how awesome is this Pfizer
and we're talking about attention spans
the James will keep the project Veritas
thing came out where one of the
directors of research or whatever is
like oh yeah we're we are in-house
mutating uh covid just to make people
have to buy and pay for new vaccines and
then look and then Pfizer just shows up
and people forgot about that story
what's crazy is Pfizer pulled all of
their advertising from Twitter when Elon
Musk bought it back in November so they
felt that Twitter any law musk was a
danger to society but then we can have
Satan worship on the Grammys oh yeah
exactly but I guess Maury told me is
that who who was watching that
performance found that entertaining I
just don't I mean it's just it's not
entertaining it isn't it really isn't
who was who was it I apologize for my uh
generation on behalf of all of us
but I will tell you though Who was the
guy that they called him Mensch he wrote
a book and we were gonna super Mensch he
wrote a book called Superman she lives
in uh Hawaii today what's Shep Gordon
you know who shot he's a documentary
yeah by the way amazing fascinating guy
Chef Gordon is do you know about his
story what he did so he he signed a lot
of different people Shep is uh uh uh Kai
you would enjoy studying this he was
around during Jimi Hendrix and all these
guys he was all their managers and stuff
he goes and stays at a hotel he's moving
to L.A because he wants to get into the
Hollywood business at the hotel he's
staying at Jimi Hendrix is staying there
a bunch of guys are staying that are not
a big name yet and they say well I need
representation he chooses to represent
them and he's working with one of the
heavy metal guys that he finds and who
is it man let me find out the dark the
it looks like a crow yeah what is their
name Alice Cooper Alice Cooper so he he
gets he represents Alice Cooper's Alice
here's what you got to do he says cut
the neck off this chicken and let the
blood pour onto your face and I'm
telling you you're gonna blow up what
the hell are you talking about he says
can you just trust me here's the chicken
bring the neck and let the blood pour
out he says are you serious he says you
hired me just trust me so anyways
obviously he listens put the pictures of
Alice Cooper and the chicken can you do
Alice Cooper chicken and then blood type
in uh blood as well right next to Tom
was G we told the story much better than
I would just put blood that Gothic crazy
look right there yeah so they they take
right their chicken to the left you see
that so he cuts the chicken's head off
the blood is right there he breaks the
neck and blood all over the place what
happens is everybody talks about it yeah
and everybody wanted to go to his next
concert and he becomes a sellout okay
all the concerts sell out so there is a
part of it where it's like you know it's
a shock Factor thing that you do but
it's just getting really old because you
know I can't think of the last time I
watched the Grammys I don't know if
people tune into it like the way they
did before okay so if you enjoyed this
clip you want to see another one click
here to watch another clip and if you
want to take advantage the latest gold
Signature Series products that just came
out we have a bunch of new merch that's
out this is a color changing mug when
you drink coffee that lion turns into a
real lion and then we have hoodies with
vitamin gold on it the gold Signature
Series hat shirts I'm an entrepreneur
anyways we have a lot of items they're
selling out if you want to take
advantage the gold Signature Series
click here place your order Sports your
right taming gear and tag us with the
hashtag valutamin
[Music]